can you imagine as an uber driver making
like a quarter or a half of your yearly
income in like one trip so he's an
example okay so you're telling me that
someone out there will see it's just the
pickup location we're sitting here door
like we're going 4000 miles where we
heading today and the moment you sit in
the car they're like crisis not only is
wrens one-wheel Mountain on fire but I
broke the 24 millimeter lens mocha that
I put in there like to see the back of
the lens moves in and out as he focused
so I put the bokeh and like snapped like
a ring off of that I fixed it all you
got to do is just see what twelves
object faraway objects and when that
lens off the camera you see nothing at
all am I gonna like take it out of the
box like a few weeks down the line so
they look and applause just gonna fall
into like 30 rings and it's really not
that bad but it was bad about five
minutes ago yeah I think I'm gonna do a
thinner version is don't-don't-don't a
friend of ours came by earlier and he
said he has access over $30,000 in uber
credits $30,000 somehow
four zeros most of my overrides are like
12 bucks is it even possible to get an
uber from Los Angeles to New York City
like how much do you think that costs
like much do you think it costs for how
far do you have to go to use up $30,000
in uber credits do you think we even
lets you alright I don't know I mean Kim
- Kim this dream even be a reality guys
just see if you can even enter in like a
destination that cost that much Empire
State Building empire from New York New
York New York I want to take an uber
black know just over X with zero axis
over a pool it's not showing canceled
okay I'm sorry - whoever accepts this
Drive also they're gonna freak out
everybody Oh a new trip just a few
minutes of money the hit accept
cuz it doesn't show you where you have
to go to drop them off and to remember
yeah can I keep the destination secret
so the drivers don't like get to pick
and choose their routes they only get to
see pickups so he's an acceptable okay
so you're telling me that someone out
there will see it's just the pickup
location we're sitting here door like
we're going okay okay once you connect
with the nearest driver okay
four minutes away guys get your stuff it
hasn't found some actual ride yet this
is like the new like call and prank like
the company down the street all right
we're gonna trip prototype Sigma Cinema
Series lens not even really even
released in most parts of the world
first thing I do put this little thing
on the back again one 4k helium sensor
fits in your pocket all the time dude
you missed a cult and I tell them are
gonna got some Sigma of these cine
lenses that they're just starting to
make they're all primes then you have
Sam's little modification for
interesting bokeh effects so we're gonna
have some hack a good footage and you
stole pants from the costume
no I bought these pants my own money
they do not belong to corridor you can't
give me to say it either lenses that we
have here 14 20 24 35 I've actually
never used 35 before we don't have a 50
we have an 85 135 but instead of a sigma
50 sam wants to test out this unique
little russian lens that he's got I
don't know for you maybe it will you the
beauty about having the cine lenses is
that everything's manual on the lens
rather than touching the screen and
whatever that your hands already ready
to go to adjust the exposure but because
you can look here there's smart lenses
they actually communicate with the
camera so we can still see what aperture
we're at he's got to get rid of the
credits because Hoover keeps canceling
his account because they think it's fake
each each person that works at Hoover
that cancels it will like discover it
and then they'll have to go through the
painstaking process of proving that it's
legit and then somebody else that works
there will find it and cancel it again
because there's like there's no way that
they have $30,000 of travel credit
youtube.com slash Sam Anika so bad these
days so yeah please six are and see what
happens the uber driver like what sir
atheria our friend had a theory
when you because the direct drive this
person can't just drive straight there
you'd have to stop overnight but you
don't cancel the drive overnight while
you stay at a hotel
you keep the meter running overnight
know if there was an automated car like
an electric car that had a battery
that's how much it would cost but with
all the sleeping and hotels and stuff
you can also paying paying for the
drivers lodging if that was an uber
driver and I got picked up and these
there was a bunch of crazy dudes with
cameras and they were like dude we're
gonna drive to New York City right now
you down
seriously have someone do that like as
soon as possible before this video gets
released hopefully we have figured out a
way to utilize these credits and send
someone on a road trip and vlog it and
it's having a pretty good prank video or
like you call an uber driver you get the
car and like let's go and they're like
okay your destination and they eat
something really spicy but try not to
show it face I guess I'll call my
daughter and tell her I'll be home late
I might mind happy come on home tonight
you all you got to do is hit that button
and get in that car these lenses are
good everything we've been filming today
it looks like I'm like 80s movie like
some 80s anamorphic movie because of it
once again my dumb backstory is Sam
didn't care about lenses for like 10
years I was just like you know if it's
in focus and it's sharp and it fits the
camera it's a good lens I didn't care
baby man big boo-boo
because we've been using Canon photo
lenses and not even like the good ones
guys over at Sigma were like hey we've
got these super cool prototype lenses
they're gonna come out soon you should
test them out and that's exactly what I
did these lenses are far better than
every other lens that we're using no
these are gonna be expensive let's don't
get me wrong these are gonna be like
probably like 3000 bucks each
maybe maybe 2,000 bucks each they are
really good though but like you starts
to see the difference that once you
compare them like even what I found
really nice about these lenses is super
crisp super clean no distortion on the
sides no Vinnie adding nothing
I love these lenses not only are they
the christmasing leoric's lenses but I
screwed him up on the back i modified
him with a 3d printed bokeh to give it
that anamorphic look sleep nope I'm not
sure but you need 85 this time I figured
it out you just have to gap tape the
bocas to the lens to the back of the one
to the back of the lens basically when
you put the bokeh at the back of the
lens it more uniformly affects the light
that's hitting the sensor versus when
you put it on the front of the lens not
not so much the case it's taking these
$3,000 lenses and making them look like
$4,000 lenses 5,000 and now and all we
did was just tape a 5 cent piece of
plastic to it alright guys let's do it
thank you whoa it's a price strip can
you can you see the destination now none
of the drivers know the destination
Maria doesn't know the fate she avoided
so should we seriously do this now yeah
it's like look how funny was just even
considering it I mean like you'll stop
being funny like two hours in once you
hit the 15 and you can't see you anymore
like goddamn should we do this I mean
seriously what would what would we do
here like do you want to do like a have
C's thing or you want to do all it's got
to be legit from outside the studio the
Empire State Building to the top of the
Empire State Building it there we could
fly back and we fly back yeah how long
would that take flying driving pull with
all the [ __ ] you'd have to do along the
way to like make it all work and
everything's probably probably like a
week Monday to Friday sort of thing what
was my shirts a repla nice spring the
Samsung phone to like constantly upload
footage because it's totally more than a
single video
well this seats out put a mattress in
the back and it's like just a little
like by the way you just realized the
person who kicks you up the first thing
you do on the trip is you go to that
person's house by the way that's the
actual first destination is we go you go
to their home you know they get their
backpacks they get a toothbrush they get
all their roadtrip supplies so it's like
it's the stories about them do they are
they are
story to know to know that you're legit
you're gonna have to give them like a
thousand dollars in cash to like just to
convince the person because if I was an
uber driver and somebody was like hey
we're going to New York I'd be like how
many drivers would you go through
standing there on the curb with your
bags like let's go like how many times
do you go through that process before so
I was like yeah let's go and they just
say in like the light I just imagine
that shot of like the person in the car
[Laughter]
hold the lottery so it's completely
random for this shows in' just like uber
nobody wants to ride in the front seat
next to the stranger so it's a big van
or a truck or SUV that's the way to go
to probably bump it up to like 8,000
though totally fine it's really funny
they haven't programmed in a mile limit
on the app why would you lose no one's
going to drive to do this world's
longest super trip the thumbnail $30,000
Hoover ride and then with the mail is
the map showing like literally how long
it is and you're like whoa 30 seconds go
by and people figure out it's not
clickbait they're in then that's when
you're in the face of someone who
realizes it's not clickbait though
they're like they're like
[Laughter]
that's what happens